bonjour mon nom et isabelle
voici mon signe
moi je voudrais monter dans un
hélicoptère
pour visiter l'île de la réunion
bonjour bonjour
moi je voudrais voir la mer vous allez
voir
à voir là non
c'est quoi ça
vous baignez vous l'avez vous paie non
voir les requins vous baigner que les
requins
je comprends pas se baigner dans la mer
ou à la mer allez voir la mer nom
est
d'accord allez voir la mer pas de
problème je note
d'accor
on peut aussi aller voir la montagne la
montagne montagne quoi la montagne
vannes
voilà
exactement la montagne
je note la montagne l'inventaire
d'accord
sinon vous et votre chose
moi je voudrais voir on dévoie
cilaos
alors ça hein c'est un s'aimer
alors de l'eau de l'eau boire
boire de loups
à cilaos si la hausse d'accord ok allez
voir si la hausse pas de progrès je le
rajoute cilaos
sinon à part si la hausse
moi je voudrais voir le volcan
non alors le feu le feu d'accord très
bien mais le feu le feu devant le
feu le feu
a le feu d'accord
le volcan c'était ça c'était le volcan
on le souhaite le volcan très bien on a
le volcan
il me reste encore autre chose
moi je voudrais voir mafate
bon allez marcher marcher non mais on
est en hélicoptère marcher
dans la montagne
la montagne marché
d'accord
mafate à mafate d'accord mafate hockey
mafate j'ai maintenant
je rajoute mafate
un dernier peut-être
je voudrais voir
salazie
un de l'eau on dire de l'eau non
d'accord de l'eau ces housses à
salazie d'accord je rajoute salazie à
l'eau le vol de l'avoir lemarié d'accord
salazie
très bien
d'écouter ces voix-là courant pas de
problème demain demain demain demain
demain je viens à quelle heure à peu
près vers 6 heures 6 à 6 heures 6 heures
d'accord vos bombes a très bien à demain
or en barre
bonjour
île de la réunion
hélicoptère
la mer
la montagne
le volcan
salazie
mafate
cilaos
au revoir